يدعو لمحو النظام في كييف بشكل كامل
معركه قضائيه جديده يخضها الامير هاري في
واشنطن
ظاهره القاء الرضع بحاويات القمامه تزداد
في سوريا
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
في بريطانيا اعلنت الحكومه انها تعتزم
ازاله جميع معدات المراقبه التي تصنعها
الشركات الصينيه من مواقعها الحساسه وذلك
في محاوله للحد من الجمع المحتمل
للمعلومات الاستخباراتيه من قبل بكين من
جهه اخرى نفت الصين وجود مراكز شرطه سريه
في المملكه المتحده مشيره الى ان
الاتهامات البريطانيه باطله حول وجود
مكاتب شرطيه صينيه هدفها ترويع اللاجئين
الاقتصاديين والمعارضين السياسيين
الصينيين الذين يقيمون في بريطانيا
ونبقى في بريطانيا ففي الوقت الذي يمثل
فيه الامير هاري امام المحكمه العليا في
لندن بشان القضيه التي رفعها ضد الناشري
صحيفه ميرور نظر القضاء الامريكي ايضا في
دعوه قضائيه رفعتها جمعيه محافظه تطالب
بمعرفه معلومات اضافيه عن التاشيره
الامريكيه الممنوحه للامير هاري رغم
اعترافه بتعاطي المخدرات في الولايات
المتحده وتطلب هذه المنظمه الحصول على ملف
الهجره الخاص بالامير هاري الذي يستقر في
كاليفورنيا منذ العام 2020 نشرت الى ان
القانون الامريكي عاده ما يجعل هؤلاء
الاشخاص غير مؤهلين للدخول الى الاراضي
الامريكيه
الى سوريا هذه المره حيث عثر على رضيعه
موضوعه داخل كيس ملقاه في احدى حاويات
القمامه في بلده السبينه بريفي دمشق فيما
تم نقلها الى المستشفى لتلقي العلاج
واجراء الفحوصات اللازمه المرفض السوري
لحقوق الانسان اشار الى تزايد حالات
التخلي عن الاطفال حديثي الولاده في سوريا
من قبل ذويهم لاسباب عديده منها العلاقات
غير الشرعيه وتدهور الواقع المعيشي في
البلاد لافتا الى ان عدد هذه الحالات
يرتفع الى 33 حاله موثقه بمختلف المناطق
السوريه خلال عام واحد
وفي خبرنا الاخير تصدرت مدينه نيويورك
الامريكيه لفتره وجيزه مؤشره اسوا تلوث
للهواء في العالم وهذا يوم الثلاثاء حيث
هبى دخان ضار جنوبا من اكثر من 100 حريق
غابات مشتعل في كندا ووفقا لشركه فقد كان
مؤشر جوده الهواء في مدينه نيويورك على
200 نقطه عند ليله الثلاثاء وهو مستوى غير
صحي للغايه ونتيجه لذلك الغت 10 مناطق
تعليميه على الاقل في وسط ولايه نيويورك
الغت الانشطه والفعاليات الخارجيه